THE DEBATE ABOUT WHAT TO DO NEXT
CAN OCCUR.
JOINING US NOW IS TERRY SEVERINO
PRESIDENT OF THE JUDICIAL CRISIS
NETWORK AND FORMER JUSTICE
THOMAS SUPREME COURT WORK AS WAS
I, OF COURSE, CARRIE HOW MUCH DO
THESE LEAKS THAT KEEP COMING?
I'M SURPRISED HOW LITTLE THIS
GOT COVERED TODAY IN THE MEDIA,
REALLY.
HOW MUCH DAMAGE IS BEING DONE TO
THE COURT, DRIP, DRIP, DRIP.
>> YEAH, IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
GETTING A PLAY BY PLAY OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL INTERACTION BEHIND
THE SCENES.
THIS IS NOT AS YOU KNOW WHAT IT
WAS LIKE WHEN WE WERE THERE.
IT USED TO BE THIS WAS ONE
BRANCH IN THE CITY THAT DOESN'T
LEAK.
SO IT'S A HUGE BREACH ON THE
COURT.
I AGREE, I HOPE THIS PERSON'S
FOUND QUICKLY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, WHAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE FROM THIS LEAK IS THAT THE
JUSTICES HAVEN'T SHIFTED, I
THINK THAT'S GOOD ON A LOT OF
LEVELS.
IT'S NOT TOO SURPRISING BECAUSE
THIS LATE IN THE TERM BOY IF
THEY'RE SWITCHING NOW YOU HAVE
TO DO A LOT OF RESHUFFLING AND
REWRITING OPINIONS I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY UNUSUAL AND I'M
GLAD TO SEE THEY HAVEN'T CAVED
TO THE PRESSURE.
>> Laura: AS A LEGAL MATTER,
WHAT'S THE STRATEGY HERE?
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT MOTIVE.
YOU ALWAYS THINK OF MOTIVE IN A
CRIME SCENE, IS IT AN ETHICAL
CRIME.
WHAT'S THE MOTIVE HERE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE I ASSUME,
IT'S A LIBERAL CLERK WHO
THOUGHT -- THIS IS KIND OF A
DESPERATION MOVE, RIGHT?
A LAST DITCH EFFORT.
WE SEE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
ROE'S GOING TO BE OVERTURNED.
BY THIS POINT IN THE TERM IF
SOMEONE WAS GOING TO CHANGE AT
ALL, WHICH IS RARE, IT PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE ALREADY HAPPENED.
SO I THINK THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS
A LAST DITCH EFFORT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BACK FIRE,
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN IT BACK FIRE
WITH THE BROAD OPPOSITION EVEN
AMONG DEMOCRATS TO THE CRAZY
PEOPLE PROTESTING IN FRONT OF
JUSTICE ALITO, THE REFUSAL OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO SAY THAT IS
BEYOND THE PAIL.
SO IT'S BACK FIRING AND IT
STRENGTHENS THE JUSTICES.
THESE ARE 20 SOMETHINGS WHO
CAN'T THINK FAR AHEAD.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK IT'S
COORDINATED AND NOT ONE PERSON.
I HAVE A NUMBER OF FRIENDS WHO
YOU KNOW PROBABLY, IT'S NOT JUST
ONE PERSON THEY BELIEVE AND THEY
THINK IT'S A COORDINATED MORE
LIKE WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE LEAK
THAT LED TO THE CONTROVERSY OVER
JUSTICE THOMAS'S CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S STILL SO
HARD FOR ME TO WRAP MY BRAIN
AROUND ONE CLERK LEAKING IN SUCH
A JOY NORM US WAY.
LEAKING THE AMONG IS BAD ENOUGH
BUT THE LEAK OF AN ENTIRE
OPINION, I DON'T KNOW.
IF THERE'S MULTIPLE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS, THAT OUGHT TO
MAKE IT EVEN EASIER FOR THE
CHIEF JUSTICE TO TRACK IT DOWN.
>> Laura: CARRIE, IF YOU AND I
OR A COUPLE OTHER FORMER CLERKS
HAD ALL THE CLERKS IN ONE ROOM,
IT WOULD TAKE US ABOUT TEN
MINUTE.
I'M SORRY, WE COULD FIND OUT WHO
THE LEAKER IS.
>> IT'S A SMALL GROUP.
>> Laura: AND WE ALL KNOW
EVERYBODY ELSE.
LIBERALS -- EVERYONE KNOWS EACH
OTHER.
HOW HARD IS THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
JUST DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT TO ME
BEYOND JUST THE LEAK.
I MEAN, COME ON, TIME'S WASTING,
LET'S FIND OUT WHO IT IS OR WHO
THEY ARE.
HERE'S WHAT JEFFREY TOOBIN SAID
TODAY ABOUT OUR FORMER BOSS,
JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS.
WATCH.
>> THOMAS HAS REPEATEDLY SAID WE
SHOULD NOT HONOR PRECEDENT IF WE
DISAGREE WITH THE RESULT AND SO
THAT MEANS HE IS MUCH MORE
WILLING TO OVERTURN PRECEDENTS
THAN OTHER JUSTICES.
HE WILL NOW HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THE SUPREME
COURT TODAY IS VERY MUCH HIS
COURT.
>> Laura: I HOPE SO.
I HOPE IT IS.
THAT'S GREAT NEWS IF THAT'S THE
CASE.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
PRE I DON'T REMEMBERTIVELY
OBVIOUSLY.
IF IT'S THE THOMAS COURT WE'RE
IN THE GREAT.
>> A COUPLE MONTHS AGO CHIEF
JUSTICE THOMAS THEY WERE GETTING
AT SOMETHING, HE IS THE
INTELLECTUAL LEADER.
>> Laura: IN IN THE ABSENCE OF
SCALIA.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE'RE SEEING, NEWS FLASH
NONE OF THE JUSTICES FOLLOW
PRECEDENT TLIBERAL JUSTICES
INCLUDED BUT JUSTICE THOMAS SAID
I WANT TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION NOT WHAT SOME GUY
SAID INCORRECTLY 50 YEARS AGO
AND THAT'S GREAT.
>> Laura: THE NEW YORK TIMES
SAID IT'S LIKE THE LEAKY BRANCH,
IT IS LEAKY NOW, BUT IT'S BECOME
SO POLITICAL.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THE COURT AND
OUTCOMES IN CERTAIN CASES HAVE
BEEN POLITICAL FOR WHAT 50, 60
YEARS?
SO NOW THE NEW YORK TIMES
DOESN'T LIKE POLITICAL COURT
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING.
>> WELCOME TO THE PARTY.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU IN STUDIO AND
REMEMBER IF YOU CAN'T WATCH US
LIVE HIT YOUR SERIES RECORD ON
YOUR